à à
anh alo chào các bạn
có thể hôm nay sẽ
không đông bằng hôm trước học lập trình
cơ bản cho dù hôm nay cũng là một kiến
thức rất là hay ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà mình không không thể gả các
bạn học chuyên sâu được đây
À hôm nay các bạn xem qua mục lục hôm
nay nhé
ở
quốc lộ hôm nay có chuyên mục rất là hay
à
ở đó là trả lời cho câu hỏi nếu hacker
hack được đã tầm bậy của bạn thì sao thì
mình
thì mình sẽ phải chờ
phòng phòng chống nóng như thế nào
mẹ con mình mình không chỉ các bạn cách
để mà thách lại được nó hay là
hay là làm nào để mà lấy lại được chuyển
dạng và bạn một là dùng tiền hay là
anh ạ ạ
khi mua tao dùng tiền này hay hack lại
đến nó là sự thế bà là xin được nó đúng
không
34 là tránh để bị hack ngờ em
làm chị có thể à
anh có khách thì nghe vui rồi đúng không
Nhưng mà
đợi mình thích à
Ừ nhưng mà mình cũng sẽ không đề cập vụ
khách ở ở trên này để mà mình gạ thêm có
người xem
cho nên nên là thôi kệ không sao cả à
ở đầu tiên thì cái vụ ép lên trên sau
này như mình đã từng nói thì các bạn có
thể thứ nhất là nên trên cái đường link
này của mình và
áo
kiểu chi chu xảy ra
nếu các bạn nên cái link này các bạn đọc
trước rồi thì có bạn sẽ thấy là hôm nay
mình sẽ dạy gần như khá là giống những
kiến thức ở trên này thôi
ở đây như thế này mình còn ghi cả tác
dụng của nó như thế nào với Vân rồi
ừ ừ
khi nghe các bạn thì gặp qua đây không
à Hôm nay thì mình sẽ học cả về Index và
view này thì ra bây giờ hết sự câu hỏi
nên thành ra lời
đang livestream hôm nay live stream sớm
như thế cả Chẳng biết nói gì
Ừ cái này thì à
à mình mình chạy mình vừa rồi Mình in
xuất trước hay bạc một bảng là
anh không Hôm nay không phải là web 3
thứ bathứ bảy sẽ là
lập trình web còn
Ừ đúng rồi Còn câu 2 sao Mình nợ hơi lâu
rồi mình xin lỗi bởi vì à thực ra cái
đấy nó là em cứ an nâng cao một tí chứ
không còn nói chuyên sâu nữa
Ừ thì bây giờ vẫn đủ thời gian để trả
lời câu đấy
cho mình xem nhé
Ừ thế bạn ở câu này đúng không
về cách nhận thông tin trên thành nhiều
bảng cho dễ quản lý lương một nhân viên
có thể nhập nhiều lần đúng không
ờ ờ còn 7 phút cho mình sẽ trả lời được
cho bạn câu này thì bài toán ở đây đó là
đầu tiên thì các bạn học ra bay đến Thời
buổi này thì các bạn cũng hình dung được
các câu lệnh thứ Thực sự thì có nhiều
bạn một con đang bỡ ngỡ việc cà rốt cuộc
là học dp chỉ để mạnh kiểu cọ những câu
lệnh hay không thôi à
axwell nó không phải mỗi thế out nó để
mặt lưu lại thông tin nữa đúng không Thì
mình quản lý thông tin thì cái câu hỏi ở
đây nếu mà bạn nào còn tưởng nhớ thì cái
đề bài nó là lưu lại thông tin của nhân
viên và lương của người đấy nếu mà hồi
đấy Mình lưu theo kiểu nhà mình mở cái
ship nhé
ở đây giả sử ở đây ngồi đấy mình nhớ
mình lưu nhân viên này
mã này tên này lương này trở lại
đại khái cơ bản như này đã nhé sửa một
này Long này đường 100 này hay một tuần
này xương 200 em ạ Nếu mà nếu mà các bạn
lưu cơ bản như này thì có hàng nó cũng
tương đối đủ rồi tương đối rồi đó là
kiểu các bạn hoàn toàn biết được Ví dụ
là thằng nay tổng tháng này thì mình sẽ
phải trả lương cho bao nhiêu nhân viên
là sử đấy có hai nhân viên đúng không
tổng mức lượng tổng số lương Một mình
phải trả là bao nhiêu là là 100 cộng 200
là ba trăm nữa ngon kê Thì nghĩa là các
bạn giải quyết được bài toán đó là các
bạn thống kê được tính toán được và
tháng này các bạn sẽ phải trả lương cho
bao nhiêu người kết hợp với việc là ở
mỗi người sẽ có những mức lương như nào
tổng lương là bao nhiêu đúng không nhưng
nó lại không giải quyết được bài toán
thống kê của quá khứ mà Kế toán lại rất
cần nhiều đấy
Vì thế nên là
thì các bạn phải lưu lại để cho kế toán
có thể thống kê lại được trong quá khứ
thì các bạn hình dung học Nghĩa là các
bạn phải lưu lại điều đấy thì các bạn
mình thống kê được đúng không thì các
bạn không thể lưu lại là lương Hôm trước
đã từng có bạn nhìn lưng cũng như này là
100 200 rồi lương mới lại là 200 300
cảnh ạ Thế này thì được ca thế này thì
cũng không đúng lắm
à à
anh Bởi vì sao Bởi vì lương cũng như này
thì không phải biết được là giúp lương
Cỗ này lương cũ Tháng mấy để mình thống
kê đúng không ra sửa lương mới lương
hiện tại nó chả Hạ Long cũng là lương
của tháng trước em ạ Thế con tháng trước
trước nữa thì sao Đúng không các bạn vẫn
rất khó thống kê được nếu mà các bạn lưu
kiểu này hay các bạn ở Lưu kiểu như thế
này lương lần 1 lương lần 2
thật sự đây là lương đàn bà
Kiểu như này nhưng mà Nếu giả sử là
anh Lương lần 3 có mỗi năm Tăng Thôi anh
Tuấn không tăng thì sao thì lại như thế
này đúng không Thế bây giờ mình tăng
lương cần 10 lần thì thì tạm thêm 10 cột
nữa
A và giúp cuộc cải lương lần một ngày
thì mình đâu nhớ được bà lương lần một
này của tháng mấy đúng không các bạn
không lương rồi Như này được đúng không
các bạn phải tách xa bởi vì sao Bởi vì
như mình đã từng nói một quan hệ
mối quan hệ bây giờ là một nhân viên có
nhiều mức lương gọi nhiều lương đúng
không
Từ từ hồi các bạn đi làm cho đến thời
điểm hiện tại với kiểu gì Các bạn sẽ
phải tăng 2 hoặc 3 lần mức lương hoặc
thậm chí bị giảm đi cũng là một mức
lương khác rồi đúng không các bạn sẽ
không phải từ trước đến nay chỉ một mức
lương nó khác với cái tên của các bạn nó
không luôn đi cùng các bạn mãi theo năm
tháng đúng không ạ
từ trước khi ông nào mà đi làm tầm ba
bốn năm mà vẫn còn một mức lương thì có
khi ông nên nghỉ Hoa ông là giám đốc
Ê mấy ông giám đốc thì toàn chơi trò
lương Một đô để không tính chị không
tính thuế ông ấy chơi lương mình cổ phần
nhưng đại sáng như thế các bạn sẽ thấy
da
11 nhân viên đúng không em hồi lương
đúng trước đi
ờ
ờ thì thì cái việc em nổi luôn này các
bạn sẽ tách nó ra thành một bản nữa thì
chưa Bảo nữa để lưu lại nó sẽ là kiểu
như này là sử Giống như mình vừa nói thì
Ừ thì có tháng mình sẽ lưu được là tháng
mấy tháng mấy thì nhân viên này lương
như thế nào là sửa đây là bạn Bảng
ở Bản Thượng Thư Cao hôm trước mình mới
đọc là bạn không nên trùng với tên cột
nên là mình không thể đặt cột vừa lương
xong rồi à
tên bạc cũng là lương được nên mình sẽ
gọi là thống kê lương nhé kiểu như này
hoặc lương theo tháng thì các bạn đặt
đúng không
và Sửa ngay sửa đây Mình lưu đương nhiên
chắc chắn mình Liêu còn lương rồi đúng
không ạ
ạ sau đó giả sử Mình lưu tháng ở ạ của
mình lưu lại mãi nhân viên là được xử
thế như này thì giờ sửa tháng 1 bạn Long
bạn lương được 100 tháng 2 bạn Long bạn
đấy lương cũng ở 100 tháng 3 bạn Long
nhưng mà lương lên là một trăm rưỡi các
bạn được xử thế thì các bạn hoàn toàn
thống kê được theo tháng theo từng nhân
viên và mức lương sẽ phải trả là bao
nhiêu nhưng mà cái này lại nhược điểm
tiếp đó là nếu các bạn lưu như thế này
thì nếu mà năm sau thì sao năm sau thì
các bạn lại bị nhầm trong tháng 1 tháng
2 mất rồi đúng không thì các bạn lại
phải tách nó ra giả sử đây một năm nữa
đã 20 20 20 20 chẳng hạn 20 21 chẳng a
20 20 nhưng là sự đây là rằm tháng 1 năm
2021 thì bạn Long này đương nhiên có thể
nhập lại được một lần nữa đúng trước
anh đúng không và bơ để tôi kiểm tra xem
mấy ông có đang tập trung 20 90 mấy ông
à Ok có vẻ là đúng rồi cái đúng với cái
số lượng mà hồi học were học này
ờ ờ Theo các bạn bảng này khóa chính là
Cột nào
a Nhớ nhớ quá chị ngon đến giờ mấy ông
trả lời được đúng cô ngày nữa thì cái
thành công Đấy
à à
Em có bạn trai đúng rồi
Em có tấm Ba bạn trả lời đúng rồi
Ừ bún Bạn chả hiểu ngon
35 bạn ok rồi có vẻ nhiều ông trời đúng
hơn hồi trước
hồi trước tao lừa quà là đúng trả lời
sai có mỗi ông một ông trả lời đúng đúng
rồi các bạn Thời gian mình đã từng nói
Nếu các bạn thực sự không Thực ra cái
này lên con này toán một tí nhưng mà
mình bảo cách giải quyết bài toán đơn
giản nhất ở đây thì thì các bạn chỉ cần
kiểm tra thôi đúng không xử là các bạn
và một mã nhân viên mà là khóa chính
thôi thì nó sáng nó say luôn rồi này bởi
vì mã nhân viên là khóa chính thôi thì
mã nhân viên lặp lại vào lỗ luôn rồi
đúng không Thế sao nữa rồi Tiếp theo Nếu
mà sánh với năm là khóa chính thôi thì
là sửa cũng là tháng 1 cũng 20 20 nhưng
nhật cho anh Tuấn và 200 Thì cái này nó
lại báo lỗi bởi vì nó bị trùng với trên
này nó rồi đúng không
Đợi mình tí à
Vì
thế nên là cách giải quyết ở đây là ba
cụ khóa chính đúng không thấy Giả sử là
bốn cột thứ như có bạn kia Và 4 Cô đóng
vai chính thì thế thì lại không đúng ý
nghĩa của khóa chính ở đây nữa Tại sao
mọi việc nếu sử mình lặp lại toàn bộ cả
cái này
à mà thay đổi lương như thế này
Ừ thì nó lạnh lại đúng đúng không Nó vẫn
chạy được nhưng mà thấy lại say mất rồi
bởi vì là lương của ông ấy nhật tháng 2
mất rồi đúng không Không phải thay đổi
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
anh theo toa là như thế nào á theo Toán
thì các bạn học về cấu trúc dữ liệu và
giải thuật thì các bạn sẽ hiểu về cái
khái niệm thỉnh thoảng mình nhắc đến
toán này là thế Mình học môn đấy như ba
lần như vậy
một lần hồi mình đi dạy em hôi một hồi
là mình đi học về sân trường một hồi là
mình đi dạy mình phải học lại dù một hồi
là mình đang học liên thông ở kiểu bởi
vì học cao đẳng nghề nên bây giờ mình
phải học liên thông để lấy cái bằng đại
học chính quy để mà về sau mình có muốn
quay trở lại đi dạy ở trường đại học thì
phải có bằng là bằng cử nhân của công
nghệ thông tin với với nhau chứng chỉ sư
phạm nữa nên là mình mới phải học tiền
không thưa các bạn xem ngày không em tin
này thì các bạn chẳng cần lấy bằng gì
lắm anh không cần bằng được vì từ trước
nay mình đi phỏng vấn ra chẳng vừa hỏi
mình bằng chẳng hỏi mình học trường nào
luôn
à à
ở đây nói chung và các bạn thì dung được
bài toán đây rồi có bạn thì sẽ có thắc
mắc với mình đó là tại sao em thấy một
tháng của năm này thì anh lưu kiểu là gì
kiểu đương nhiên là kiểu nó số của nó sẽ
kiểu in hoặc xơ có bạn bảo hết Tại sao
anh không lưu lại một cột vào cột ngày
tháng năm rồi lưu lại kiểu bếp bởi vì
mỗi khi các bạn biết đại khái niệm
thường ngày tháng năm gắn liền với bếp
đúng không Nhớ thế không đúng nữa bởi vì
là cái này tính cho cả tháng đấy và năm
đấy còn nếu mà bạn lưu kiểu dạng là nếu
Gọi Lưu thì kiểu này hay không mưa này
tháng 1 này một như này để lưu lại nhân
viên như này Ừ thì hoàn toàn là
a hoàn toàn thì nay lại không đúng bởi
vì các bạn hoàn toàn thể bị ngập sang
ngày mùng 2 cũng là tháng 1 cũng nhân
viên một và 200.000 nay đúng không
Thế thế thế thế nên là cái ý lưu lại đầy
đủ cả dạng bếp như này lại không đúng
nếu các bạn chỉ lưu lại theo dạng như
nào chuẩn này tự nhiên ở đây bài toán
vẫn còn cơ bản một tí thôi còn nâng cao
hơn nữa giống như là nhiều phần mềm
chuyên nghiệp bây giờ làm về kế toán
thống kê lương thì nó phức tạp hơn
ờ ờ
Ok Đấy là chữa cho câu hay sao cho bạn
Linh
Còn bây giờ thì mình xin phép là bây giờ
mình sẽ quay lại bên A
ở bên này đúng không Bên nhiều nhiều bạn
on hơn rồi thì các bạn những Hãy Để ý kỹ
mục lục này nha đúng không Tí mình sẽ
nói cho qua này hãy cùng một tí thế nên
là ông làm ở kiên nhẫn chờ đến cuối được
thì sẽ có thêm rất nhiều cái thứ hai để
mà xem đúng không ạ
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ nói qua về Index
Nếu các bạn xem qua trên trang của mình
thì các bạn sẽ biết qua Nói chung mình
những giải thích khá rõ cái là ví dụ như
là mình sẽ không dạy các bạn theo kiểu
đó là kiểu mình đọc lại toàn bộ những
cái trên này mà mình sẽ đưa thằng bài
toán thực tế luôn cho các bạn
anh ở đây sẽ có khái niệm giả sử ở đây
mình đã in xuất trước một bạn là 100.000
bản ghi
ở đây như thế này đấy thì bây giờ giả sử
Mình muốn lấy
mình muốn lấy một bạn tên tên gì nữa
Ví dụ ở bên như này đi
ở trong danh sách này tên này mình đang
để lên ta tinh bởi vì mình đang vừa rồi
mình vừa chạy câu lệnh Insert
Anh vào trong cái bảng này
linh tinh để tên côn trùng vân vân chia
tên này thì ra trái nghĩa gì cả Bây giờ
mình sẽ có khái niệm gia sửa Selection
for sinh viên đúng không bạn sinh viên
mà Where họ bằng này chẳng hạn đúng
không các bạn thử xem mình chạy mất bao
lâu nhé
thì kệ nó tốn không phải
2047 giây đúng không
ô chữ k thế này ra khá nhanh bạn thì
nhanh phết đúng không Bởi vì sao về các
bạn 100.000 bản ghi mai Quest tại vẫn
được
ạ
Bây giờ mình có ở bên bảng sinh viên 1
ở đây là
997 nhìn màn GB là gần một triệu bản ghi
thì tốc độ xử lí nó sẽ ra sao đây mình
thử cho tên nằm ở 996 này chạy thử này
sinh viên 1
Ừ nó ra Các bạn thấy nó lên 0,3 giây Tuy
là các bạn thấy à không phải ba dây
nhanh mà anh đúng không Nhưng mà không
bài toán các bạn đây mình chỉ ra một ví
dụ điển hình về một triệu bạn ghi Còn
thực tế và các bạn làm đôi khi không
phải là một triệu mà thể
ạ Bây giờ là Facebook lưu thông tin của
Hà Lưu mỗi
có mỗi cái bảng tài khoản người dùng mà
đã là hơn mấy tỉ mấy tỉ rồi mà đương như
các bạn không không hình dung nó là kiểu
1 tỷ Sau đó một triệu thì nó nó gấp
1.000 lần nhân lên 1.000 lần dây không
phải như thế đâu mà nó hoàn toàn khác
thật chứ nó nằm chết luôn cả con hệ Con
sờ các bạn và có thật
ạ
Và nếu mà các bạn tìm theo kiểu là hồi
trước các bạn nhớ về cái vụ là tìm tên
kiểu gần giống tên yêu kiểu là là sử giờ
bắt đầu bằng chữ quy này chẳng hạn thì
mình sẽ là like này xong ngồi QR rằng
sau Kính tự như thế này thì các bạn thấy
là tốc độ nó lên đến thứ ba thằng ngày
mai còn nhanh này
Ừ cái này báo đã tùy tình huống có thể
lên đến theo lấy Quốc này có thứ như là
nói chung các bạn thấy đại khái nó như
thế tốc tốc độ nó có thể bị ảnh hưởng
rất nhiều nếu mà truy vấn rất là nặng
đúng không
Anh ngồi đây
ông Đặng Minh thích bệnh nhân tỉnh Copy
lại nhé ừ ừ
chị xem này 0,3
0,39 mốt đây đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ
chỉ các bạn về cái để mà khắc phục cái
này để cho tốc độ nó truy vấn rất nhanh
anh Bởi vì cho các bạn thấy cùng bảng
này cùng bảng sinh viên một này nhé mình
copy ra này
mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ lấy Theo các bạn thấy mã đây
bằng 37 đúng không Mình vẫn sẽ lời que
mãi bằng 37 nhé Đúng không
ở các loại tốc độ nó khác biệt cực đây
Các bạn thấy tốc độ là bao nhiu
thì các bạn thấy So sánh không một cái
là
à à
có một cái là gần như không mất 11 m đây
nào một cái là đây
ở mức 0,3 giây đúng không
Ừ thì các bạn thấy là cái nào nó nhanh
hơn chắc chắn là cái không không mất hẳn
1 Mini đây là nhanh hơn đúng không phải
giải quyết bài toán ở đây đó là tại sao
nó lại như thế cho dù rõ ràng là nó cung
trong cái bảng sinh viên một cơ mà Đúng
không Nó cùng mã màn 37 cơ mà đúng không
Thì tại sao nó lại nhanh nhìn thế Các
bạn nhớ vụ hồi tạm bạc
vì sao mình nhớ mình vừa mình đi câu
lệnh tạo Bạc á Chắc là mình sáng rồi
mình nhớ đây mình ghi lại có lệnh thoại
bàn nhá á
em
là sinh viên à đúng không
Ừ mình đi lại cho các bạn nhớ này mã này
I này
khi họ này
bà Trà 50 chẳng ạ tên này cũng va tra
50 rằng ạ và file Mickey La Mã sử là nó
cứ tự động tăng nhé
chỉ đúng một phần bạn kia nói đúng một
phần là nó là do kiểu dữ liệu nữa nhưng
một phần là các bạn nhớ cái khái niệm
nào cái mà mình cũng vừa hỏi quay Mickey
là phải trình đúng không Ừ đúng chưa thì
cái khóa chính này nó là duy nhất đúng
không các bạn vẫn nhớ được khái niệm đấy
đúng không và cái trình cái duy nhất này
họ sẽ luôn
thì nó sẽ luôn
gọi là nó sẽ luôn tạo ra một cái gọi lại
Index cho nó và Index đầy nó sẽ để tốc
độ truy vấn theo và Iraq Đấy tốc độ sẽ
nhanh hơn rất nhiều về chưa
Ừ nhưng mà đây là trong trường hợp mà
các bạn
anh thấy bảo Funiki
thì nó như này thôi còn nếu mà các bạn
không khai vào primakey tốc độ truy vấn
của cái mã vừa rồi hết nó cũng phải lên
những không phải mấy giây kể cả nhà mình
mình hẹn tiếp hả Mình chẳng có ví dụ gì
đây cả vì sao mình có thể dốc cái Index
nó đi cũng được nhưng mà thôi Bây giờ
mình sẽ dạy cho các bạn thẳng luôn không
không cần thêm ví dụ nữa
ở đây Các bạn thấy là có hai kiểu Index
là crestor và non Plus thực ra mình phát
âm tiếng anh vẫn 402 nên các bạn có qua
lại nhé Thì
Xin chào các bạn bè quay lại cái mà mình
vừa nói vừa rồi mình bảo primakey mặc
định sẽ cho nó cái ếch đúng không chép
đủ các bạn biết thì cái
các
bạn ạ
Ừ tôi sẽ chạy đi một tí
ở bản đồ các bạn biết là cài tameiki nó
sẽ tự động tạo Index crestor hai non
clusters cho bạc
Ừ đúng rồi bạn Phương Linh và vừa nói
một câu rất là hay nó không diệt từng tự
nữa mà nó nhảy tới Yên đấy Đúng rồi
chính xác chính xác rồi đấy bạn đó là
khi mà tạo Index nó giống như kiểu các
bạn tạo một cái một cái bảng riêng và
bảng mục lục để mà các bạn lưu lại mấy
cái ở trong đấy và các bạn chị tra trong
đấy rồi nó sẽ ánh xạ ra cái bảng góc để
mà lấy được thông tin chuẩn thế nên là
tốc độ truy vấn của Cái bàn kia vốn nó
để tìm kiếm thì nó sẽ nhanh hơn rất
nhiều ở đây trả ông nào đoán nó non cả
đúng không Ok thì ở đây các bạn sẽ phải
biết thêm một tí khái niệm về crestor
này vừa non grasses này nó khác gì nhau
đây
Ừ thứ nhất là một bảng chỉ có một Index
crestor thôi Được chưa
Vì thế nên là tức là khi mà các bạn đã
lỡ khai báo waikiki cho cái bảng này
rồi thì nó tự động đánh Thresh teledex
đúng không Thì tức là các bạn không thể
tạo cài Inax crestor cho bà ngày nữa ở
trên cột khác đây giả sử và mình sẽ có
câu lệnh là class
class telnet này nó ngon ơ
đề nghị quyết đúng rồi nhá đúng không
Hai Màu nó bị thế
anh làm sao Đúng đấy ạ
ờ ờ
on-device nhớ on thông cảm mình không
nhớ
thì không Lâu lắm không làm cái này
Inax tên chẳng ạ
on sinh viên một tên này à
3000 mình mình xin lỗi cái này là như
không chạy được ở trên máy nãy giờ mình
đang để mô Nếu mà bạn để ý kĩ thì mình
đang để mô trên máy kia Tại sao thế Mình
xin phép phải mở lại em qua server SQL
Server thì cú pháp nó chuẩn hơn mà có
mấy cái crestor này còn máy kia thì mình
nhớ lời thì ra cũng có như cũng phát một
khác mình dậy rồi các bạn thì sẽ dạy các
bạn về em qua server để má cú pháp chuẩn
để mà các bạn người sang bất kỳ Apple
nào khác thì các bạn sẽ không bị bỡ ngỡ
lắm
Ừ nhưng mà tại sao hôm nay mình lại để
mô các bạn bằng mai que o mà không phải
qua server ngay từ đầu bởi vì là mình
mình Insert 1 triệu bản ghi này mình
không để yên suốt bằng tay được một
triệu bản ghi cho sẵn rồi mình sẽ bật
lập trình ra các đoạn này mà lập trình
của mình thì mình đang dùng ngôn ngữ p
nên mình chỉ kết nối đến máy kéo thôi
mình không kết nối được với Access
Server này để mà Insert thành ra là các
bạn thấy ra
thể thấy là mình để mô để mô ví dụ thì ở
trên máy queo nhưng mà còn bây giờ để
nhảy sang về ghi các câu lệnh thì chắc
là mình phải chuyển qua bên này cho nó
chuẩn
ở đây mình cứ tạo lại bảng trước nhé
mình copy câu lệnh tại bản đi
đã sửa mình copy này
ở Tuy nhiên các bạn thấy chạy À đây có
bạn sinh viên không ạ Đây mình tạo hẳn
read data base
buổi mua đây Chắc thế Chắc bạn chưa có
phần tóc bên này đâu
ở đó sao mình sẽ yêu buổi một đúng không
ạ
cho
các bạn khi mà học cái này cũng thế các
bạn nên chạy cốt hết ở trên Apple server
nhé
ạ Bây giờ giả sử và mình tạo xong bạn
này ổn rồi đúng không ạ sau đó thì mình
sẽ flash jester
đó rõ ràng Bên này bên này màu vẫn thấy
chúng tôi gõ sai gì rồi
a
clusters à
em không nhớ mình đã sai thì luôn Index
này intek tên lại chẳng lại on sinh viên
tại cột tên này chẳng
Ai bày mình chạy thu vụ này các bạn sẽ
thấy là không thể tạo một à hơn lớn hơn
một cái classmate trên bảng sinh viên mà
phải lốp cái crassna cũ mà liên quan đến
file key chưa
ừ ừ
xe
tải như này thì các bạn thấy đấy thì lý
thuyết thế đó là kiểu các bạn không thể
tạo được một collectiondx y hệt
à không phải một class rách nữa đúng
không Thế bây giờ mình thử tại một non
rồi vắt xơi nước thì sao họ sẽ non như
thế này này chỉ các bạn hoàn toàn tạm
được gì chưa và
A
và đương nhiên là bây giờ bên bên này
thì dữ liệu toàn bộ là mới này là thực
ra các bạn không Không biết kiểm tra tốc
độ nó như thế nào nhưng mà về cơ bản thì
đều các bạn tìm kiếm theo quay tên thì
nó sẽ nhanh Hình như cái này chạy được
trên máy của em đấy mình xin phép mình
thử thử chạy mình chưa thử rồi
anh không chạy được
Ừ để xóa đi Hình như cái này chạy được
đấy
ở đó Cái này chạy được
thì các bạn thấy tốn cũng lần này thời
gian không phải ba giây để nó đánh Index
toàn bộ lại cho cái bảng Sinh Viên Hoa
sinh viên một thì còn nặng nữa này
a bánh Intex cho bạn sinh viên một mà 1
triệu bản ghi là tốn tận 3 giây thì chưa
yêu Bây giờ các bạn thử tìm kiếm theo
tên
em vừa rồi tìm kiếm với họ nhá Nhưng bây
giờ mình tìm kiếm tên của bạn sinh viên
một thì bạn sẽ thấy tốc độ nóng nhanh
như thế nào là sự là
có
hẳn một cái tên đó chắc chắn không tồn
tại đi Bể để xem nó sẽ phải quét cả cái
bàn thì nó sẽ tồn bao lâu đúng
thì các bạn Thủy Diệu
thì các bạn thấy tốc độ nó lại nhanh
bằng cái Index plaster rồi được đúng
không là chẳng mất không phải máy Desire
gì cả đúng chưa Nếu khi các bạn bánh đấy
còn nó rồi nhưng đây mới vẫn chỉ là bài
toán 1 triệu bản ghi Đây là các bạn thấy
tốc độ nó vẫn từng đồ ấy à nhanh nhưng
mà nếu mà các bạn đến tâm như mình nói
đến tỉ và ghi chứ thìa cháo nó sẽ lên
đến có thể là tùy server nữa ví dụ bằng
máy với các bạn mà không đủ khỏe là chết
luôn đó server chị chứ không phải đã trả
lại cái quả được như này các bạn đâu gần
đây mình có làm ở bên công ty mình cũng
phải biết được mấy cái vụ này bởi vì
công ty mình đưa nó lên mới chịu bạn đi
rồi
ở
đó thì vừa rồi là các bạn biết qua về
cái á Index nhưng mà Ngoài ra mình Sufat
mình nói thêm một vài nữa khái niệm nữa
đúng rồi Facebook có dùng máy queo nhé
Mình đã từng nói ở ngay buổi đầu tiên ý
đó là Facebook dùng máy queo
Ê thằng FL Server này thực của Microsoft
thực cao lại ít ít công ty dùng một phần
là nọ mất phí năm 1 và là
lập trình viên mình có vẻ quen dùng máy
queo hơn nó dễ học hơn thằng em kia
servo là nó kiểu bị văn mẫu á bị kiểu nó
có ký hiệu nó giống kiểu ngôn ngữ lập
trình suy hiểu Ít người nghĩ người thích
cái đấy hàng ra là kiểu ít người lập
trình về cái đấy này nha nguồn nhân lực
nó cũng ít
à à Một cái công ty lớn ở nó sẽ dùng rất
nhiều cái thứ hiện lưu ảnh trong bê của
nó bao gồm cả nấu Maxwell và có thể có
cảm thêm ashwell để mà kiểm tra chặt chẽ
với dữ liệu nữa Thế nên là
không thể nói thằng thằng Facebook Chỉ
dùng một cái loại cơ sở dữ liệu được
nhưng có một vài thẳng mình nhớ không
lầm là một vài hàng nó vẫn có thể đã
dùng chỉ 01 loại cơ sở liệu
Ê thằng đấy Mình nhớ không lầm là thằng
gần đây ở thằng ít hấp thì vậy
anh đi Thấp bán chè à
À hôm trước Chính Anh Tuấn đăng cái bài
là thằng Tít hát này phải tối như sao
cho mà mai cao của nó có thể chịu được
đến gần như trăm nghìn được truy vấn mỗi
một giây trăm nghìn lượt kiểu trăm nghìn
câu select một giây mà trong cái đó dữ
liệu của nó bây giờ lên đến mấy mấy chút
tỉ thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cái bài toán
Thứ nhất là server của nó máy chủ của nó
rất là khỏe chứ ai là nó phải tối ưu tất
cả những cái câu rách mà đương nhiên nó
chết sống lại đánh nách thằng Google
Nhấn thằng Google phải đánh Index rất
nhiều chứ
à à
Ừ thì ở đây mình mình à Mình có nói qua
thêm về vụ là Gangster nó khác gì non
prester John non với crestor vừa rồi và
mình để mô tiền 1 triệu bản ghi thành ra
là nó vẫn quá ít để mà các bạn thấy được
sự khác biệt về tốc độ truy vấn của nó
Các bạn thấy nó vẫn là không không đi
đây này ra các bạn không thể so sánh
được nho class sẽ trả mà luôn nhanh hơn
là non crestor để cười nhất thứ hai là
anh Bởi vì sao Bởi vì crestor là nó sẽ
sắp xếp lại và non-class không sắp xếp
lại mình sẽ có một ví dụ ở đây để các
bạn dễ hình dung hơn là sử không ra sự ở
bên này đi em này sẽ đây
ạ Bây giờ sửa là mình có nhân viên đây
mình có một triệu nhân viên đúng không
thì khi mà mình đánh Index kể code Cái
này là cholesterol này và cái này non
Plus này chẳng hạn đấy Hoa Cà
anh hoặc giả sử Mỹ họ đây Nguyễn
Mạnh này
giả sử là họ đây mình đánh Inax là các
classes nhé và thằng tên mình là những
đấy cả non-pressure xử thế là xử nó
không có giả sử quần mã 01 đánh
eelektross sơ được ạ đúng không ý Thì
cái cresta này nó sẽ khi mà vào bảng đấy
thì nó vẫn sẽ kiểu đứng nhiên là nó
không giữ nguyên đúng cái chỗ ấy nhất là
cả hai thằng không đều không giữ nguyên
cái chỗ ấy của nó mà luôn quy ước lại
dụng Nguyễn này Thành miễn này nó sẽ
hiểu
chứ không phải À đúng rồi Nguyễn Nguyễn
này nó sẽ hiểu nó bằng là một chàng ạ
xong rồi mạnh này thì nó sẽ bằng là hai
cả ạ đứng nhờ kem
à Mà không phải một đi mình cho hằm con
số ở đó đi
có
gì đấy Đây đúng không là gì thì đấy đây
đi xử như thế này một số bất kì không
liên quan đến mã thằng này đâu nha
đứng yên là ngoài cái này ra nó có nó có
một cái đường Linh nữa là sự đêm một cái
link này
mình
Tại sao tự nhiên mình để cập với Linh ở
đây bây giờ xử là bên mình tìm kiếm dựa
trên họ và họ Nguyễn đúng không nó sẽ ra
đứa con số này đúng
khi
con số này bạn nó sẽ
Ừ cái này là quy ước nhé Cái này là quy
ước tôi bản chất là con số này nó sẽ
được sắp xếp rồi
A
và đấy mình mình có đi cập ở đây là nó
sẽ được sắp xếp thứ tự tăng dần rồi để
nó kiểm tra việc là cái Inax Này tốc độ
xử lý
ăn nhanh ở nó được sắp xếp lại đây
khi dùng từ nó nãy giờ nó đang hơi bị
khó hiểu một tí để chúng mình ghi lại
cho bạn sẽ hình dung hơn Đợi mình thích
à
đi
dép này
ở đây đây đã sửa ngày đi mình xin phép
sửa lại cậu từng tí cho nó dễ hiểu hơn
nhá 12
21 24 đi
giá DC đi dạo này rét đi vào đây 25 - ok
nó như thế này
mình nó mới Lật lại một lần nữa nhé
ra xử mình tìm kiếm những cái bạn có họ
là họ ai chả nạn đúng không Thì ah nó sẽ
tương ứng với một hai ba này đúng không
em và nó sẽ chỉ lấy tất cả những cái bạn
nào mà từ 123 kèm theo link của tất cả
những các bạn Đấy thấy chưa link của bạn
đấy dụng ở link này nó sẽ Linh đến cái
bạn mã là một mã bạn ở dưới này ra sự mã
bạn đấy là năm thằng bạn có ai là tên là
ABC chọn thế link này nó sẽ mau gồm cả
bạn một bạn nam được chưa ạ
tủ lạnh tại sao mình thể thế nên là đấy
do mình để cập Linh ở đây Linh này nó sẽ
Linh được đến hai thằng cùng lúc và họ
kia các bạn Nhật và A thì bản chất nó sẽ
ở 123 vào nó sẽ tìm kiếm rất là nhanh
theo kiểu là
a123 nó tìm ra một hai ba nó không lướt
xuống đến 1242 250 nữa chưa Đấy do tốc
độ xử lý của nó nhanh
con Hằng còn thằng non preston này thằng
non-pressure thì bản chất của nó lại
không không như thế này
vì nó không được sắp xếp thì cả chẳng
qua nó cái từ tên của nó như này
đúng tên của nó ngày nó sẽ biến thành
một cái chuỗi nào đó cũng là thành và
chỗ ở đó cũng thèm ngủ Cái Linh ở đó như
là nó không được sắp xếp thì cả à
ở tại sao nãy giờ mình phải Đề cập về vụ
sắp xếp bởi vì Giả sử nhá mình nhập cái
tên là
Em à mình mình tìm kiếm tìm kiếm đi Tìm
kiếm tên là B ạ Nó họ là bê chứ họ B ạ
Ờ thì đầu tiên thì nó chỉ việc tìm kiếm
xem là cái bê này nó có tương ứng gì đến
trong cái bạn này không thôi
ở Tân ấn với cái số nào trong máy không
Không có gì nó phản hồi về rất là nhanh
đấy Cái thứ nhất cái thứ hai Nếu giả sử
nó là
a nói B mở trong BB trong này cũng có
và nó là
125 đi vào đây 124 đi
nó sẽ tìm kiếm được tất cả những bạn bê
dựa
a b nói bánh xanh thành 124 đúng không
và nó sẽ Linh được tất cả bạn đấy và nó
sẽ không để ý đến 12 năm 250 nữa
Ừ
đúng rồi bạn kia nói nó cũng na ná kiểu
từ Thằng này nó sẽ đùi chiếu sang thằng
kia ấy cái nó hơi bị mông lung một tí
nhưng mình đang cố giải hết cho nó dễ
hiểu hơn chứ bạn tra anh trai trên mạng
bây giờ về mình cái khái niệm intek này
có khi còn ông đúng hơn
nhưng đại khái là các bạn hiểu là nó như
thế nó sẽ luôn sắp xếp Vậy à đoạn này
thì ra mình đang bị Hơi sàn gì nhé là nó
còn sắp xếp loại luôn
Ừ để không không không xảy ra tình lượng
tình trạng bê Đầy súng cuối ở đâu ra sự
mình thêm đàng bê sáng bên phải đến trên
như thế này mới đúng nó sẽ nhảy đến đúng
thằng B này thôi và nó không để đến
thằng C nữa mà nếu mà thằng B giờ Nếu
giả sử mà mình tìm kiếm cho thằng bêđê ạ
thì nó nó kiểm tra nhé B trong mày không
tồn tại thì nó cũng sẽ thông báo các bạn
luôn đấy việc nhanh của thằng Inn
Express tơ của vì nó đã được sắp xếp rồi
còn Chính vì Inax non Blaster là không
được sắp xếp Nên là các bạn sẽ hiểu là
nó sẽ nôn kiểm tra từ đầu đến cuối của
cái bàn Inax để mà
Ừ để mạc kiểu ra được ra được chính xác
là thằng đấy có tồn tại trong trong cái
bà này hay không đấy mình mình cha mình
đúc kết được mỗi thế
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây nhá Ở đây Chính vì thế
nhá
từ nãy giờ mình nói hơi bị
mãi mãi một tí mình xin lỗi nhưng mà
công nhận cái này là khó hiểu mà nếu bạn
nào biết qua cái này rồi thì ở đây mình
xin phép thử hỏi thêm các bạn một câu ra
giả sử là bây giờ mình đánh Inn Express
mình đánh đất rồi đúng không Nói chung
mình cứ làm như đất đá đúng không
ăn thịt heo các bạn là việc là nếu mình
không làm như đấy Nếu không là Iraq như
thế này
so với việc mình đánh Iraq
Ừ Thì
sau khi mà Insert update này
Insert update Delete
khi đánh Index
20 ngày nhưng ấy
thì cái nào anh ơi
em vừa rồi Các bạn hãy rõ ràng mà đánh
hình ảnh Index để và câu c của mình chạy
nhanh hơn
anh đúng không Đây bình tĩnh mình sẽ ra
thích các bạn về cụ thể sự khác biệt
giữa sân crestor vietnamplastic cũng
thông qua các này
Ừ thì các bạn
thấy là ix7 enactus Iraq chạy nhanh hơn
này đúng không Nhưng còn Insert update
Delete thì việc bàn Inax nó khiến cho nó
chạy nhanh hơn nữa hay ở phía nó nó chạy
chậm hơn
à à
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn hiểu được vấn đề đấy
các bạn trả lời đúng nó này đúng là các
bạn hiểu được vấn đề rồi Đúng là chuẩn
rồi đây này thì các bạn vừa rồi dễ hình
dung rồi đúng không Nghĩa là mình thêm
một cái bạn nào đó đây nữa sửa mình
Insert thêm một bạn ở đây đúng không
em ngủ trưa đi xuất Thế bạn ở đây nếu mà
không này đấy Thì đúng là mình chỉ in
rất là xong lại thôi đúng không Con do
là mình đã đánh Index vào rồi nên là nó
phải cập nhật lại bằng đấy đúng rồi
Vì thế nên là bây giờ các bạn trả lời
được con này rồi đúng không Bạn lại trả
lời câu nữa khó hơn một tí đó là thế bây
giờ bài toán là ở cùng này nak là
classes.dex và non classmate thì thằng
Hào khi mày Insert update English
classes và non-class đúng không khi
thằng nào khi mà khi mạnh Insert update
Delete thì thằng nào chạy nhanh hơn
à à
thì
rõ ràng thì vừa nãy có rẻ có trả lời
được bài toán là crestor in decan sẽ
select nhanh hơn đúng không Bây giờ bù
lại nếu mà Insert update Delete thì
thằng cras neque non precedex
Ừ tao nó sẽ khiến có lệnh chạy nhanh hơn
nhanh hơn nữa không phải trợ mưa nó nhé
Ừ đúng rồi bạn Các bạn có vẻ
Anh hiểu vấn đề đấy chứ khuya hơi lú một
tí nhưng mà thầy Mình thấy là các bạn
trả lời đúng hết thì chuẩn rồi
Ừ cái cái cái cái này nó dễ hiểu rồi mà
đúng không Bởi vì các bạn thấy à Vừa rồi
Vừa nãy mình cũng phải làm lại các bạn
thế khá mất công về việc là a
AC số tự nhiên nhập thêm một bạn bê nữa
thì mình lại phải mình lại phải cho Sắp
xếp nó lại đúng không Mình lại sắp xếp
lại cho nó thay vì non Blaster thì mình
chỉ tượng Insert vào vào luôn thêm một
cái mới còn còn thằng Index cluster thì
mình lại phải sắc mình ngoài việc mình
Asus thì mình phải sắp xếp lại đúng
không ạ
Ừ mình dậy lấy hiểu á Không cái đoạn vừa
nãy mình cảm thấy ra sợ hơi khó với các
bạn Các bạn thấy lú rồi à
ở miền Nam cố mình đang cố truyền đạt
một cách
dễ hiểu thì một phần nhưng mà cũng phải
đủ kiến thức nên là có nhiều đoạn mình
sẽ công nhận nó khó nó hơi bị bay não
một tí
Ừ nhưng mà như mình đã từng nói thì các
bạn phải đau não một tí thì các bạn mới
mới gọi đang học đúng không
à à
ở đó thực ra là thực ra là chính vì các
bạn vừa rồi nghe cái vụ này Insert
update Delete đã khiến cho tui is-7 Inax
khiến cho câu select nhanh hơn thật
nhưng mà bù lại thì Insert update Delete
nó sẽ bị chậm hơn đúng không thành ra là
lời khuyên là không áp dụng cho bạn có
ít bạn Nhi này các bạn đừng có lạm dụng
việc iPad này thử là nó không được tốt
lắm khi mà các bạn không biết đánh nó
chuẩn các bạn không đánh chuẩn các bạn
cứ đánh cột nào đánh elac ạ Thế quá sai
cột chỉ có thương ai xe lách nhiều Where
theo cột đấy nhiều thì mình nên này như
thế này hoặc và bạn phải có nhiều bản
ghi Nói chung là mai que vừa rồi Các bạn
thấy là một triệu bản ghi thì may ra là
tốc độ của các bạn nó bị chậm đúng không
Thế nên là các bạn tốc độ nếu mà các bạn
làm cái phần mềm rất là bé thôi Kiểu này
chỉ có trăm nghìn mà nghĩ thôi thì các
bạn không cần phải đánh Index cho nó ừ ừ
A và tiếp theo là cụt mặc thường cập
nhật thường xuyên giá trị như này lại
đúng không là các bạn phải đồng nghĩa về
các bạn phải sửa lại Index rất nhiều nên
là cũng không nên đánh bài mien Bac cho
cái cốt đấy
I và cột nhiều chứa chứa nhiều giá trị
rỗng nó nun thực ra là nun thì khi mà sẽ
lách thì nó luôn luôn Bỏ qua Bởi vì các
bạn nhiều không Các bạn nhớ khi mà câu
lệnh select các bạn Where
ví dụ họ các bạn sẽ phải bằng hoặc à
Like gì đó các bạn nhiều không Còn nếu
mà các bạn so sánh luôn thì các bạn sẽ
Các bạn nhớ so sánh như thế nào để mà họ
là luôn không
Xin chào Trả lời nhanh câu này phát nào
là nó để kiện để mà lấy ra những bạn có
họ là nôn
ừ ừ
à à
ở nhà ông đâu rồi Hay là do tôi để chat
cho đúng rồi Các bạn thấy là nó sẽ khác
biệt hoàn toàn nó sẽ không còn bằng
không còn like nữa mà nó sẽ ít Nhung
đúng không Nghĩa là cái này nó không
liên quan đến Iraq nữa nó liên quan
thẳng cái khác rồi thành ra là đó không
có tác dụng gì mấy thì các bạn Ánh Index
và 10 cái trường đó là nun đúng không
nghe các bạn hãy bỏ quan
không không nên kiểu bạn đâu đánh đấy
hồi hồi mình học mới học db2 này nhé Rất
nhiều ông được hưởng mềm về đánh tất cả
cột trong bảng này nhìn đấy rồi ông ấy
chạy có Insert cho cho một cái bàn có
trăm nghìn mà ghi hôi mồ côi sơ của ông
đấy vậy mất 23 giây liền chỉ vì ông này
đánh ấy rất vô tội vạ à
Ừ thế thì nên là các bạn phải cân nhắc
về một cái vụ này không ạ
ở đây và các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây mình có
nói thêm đây vừa rồi mình có đề cập là
cột họ có thể để nó là inecraft được
được nhá Không phải là một cứ cột
vanmiki là nó sẽ đương nhiên nó sẽ tự
động đẩy nấy crestor nhưng mà trong
trường hợp các bạn không khai bảo nó khi
mà tạo bảng này thôi các bạn mà khai báo
nó là Inax cluster đây này các bạn khai
báo
i i max pressure
ở
tại cổ tên là
em tên gì vậy trí nhớ không lầm như thế
này
các bạn khai báo như này trước chẳng hạn
thế Mình nhớ mình nhớ không Mình không
nhớ chính xác về cái xe báo này lắm Đấy
nó đang bảo lỗi nhưng thực ra là mình
như mày mình nhớ là các bạn khai báo lúc
mà các bạn tạo bảng này và Inax plaster
ở cột khác không phải là cột cột 20 ký
thì
sau khi hoàn toàn các bạn làm được vụ
đấy thì cái cột mã các bạn sẽ không được
là những cách nữa Chuyển làn để thôi
Ừ
có đánh đấy nhưng mà không này nick tô
nữa mà chỉ đánh Index non-pressure và nó
sẽ như một cái Index của unique như thế
này các bạn đọc ở đây nhá cột Yoona cũng
phải bánh Winx Club mặc định nó sẽ luôn
lạnh Inax non-pressure này khoai Miki
thường mặc định sẽ in Express Air Nhưng
mà nếu mà các bạn khai báo trước khai
báo trước cột in Explorer là cột khác
thì quay Mickey nó sẽ được và những nách
của unix như bình thường và non-class
thôi à
a bánh đất thì mình có chỉ có lệnh đây
rồi Nếu mà mình dại giống nhiều thầy cô
mình đã từng gặp hoặc cả chính hồi mà
mình đi học nhé Mình chia sẻ thực tế đó
là thầy mình dậy đúng có mỗi câu này
thôi là hết một bài Index và chỉ đơn
giản Thầy bảo là Inax cả để cho xe lách
nhanh hơn hết
cơ hội đấy mình cảm thấy học môn db2 này
rất chán Chỉ vì lý do đấy bởi vì sai cậu
bởi vì a mol p2 thời gian mà rất khó rất
khó về lý thuyết Nhưng mà thực hành nó
thực ra không khó lắm Bởi vì các bạn
thấy nó chỉ có một câu lệnh Dương nhắn
nhé là xong
Ừ ông ấy con biết trên đúng của dòng nha
nghe xong hết hết buổi học
thì các bạn có thể đi về kiểu cái thế
pin
Vì thế nên là kiểu mình đang cố đang cố
à Nó những cái nó gọi trên sông một tí
các bạn học qua cái Index này ở trên
trường rồi các bạn sẽ thấy là ngồi cái
này cô em không lấy dậy này hoặc là bây
giờ mới biết vân vân vân
ừ ừ
Em hãy trước nãy giờ thì ra Các bạn thấy
có bạn vừa rồi hỏi đấy câu lệnh đi tạm
Yên Bái cái gì đúng không có lợi nó chỉ
ngắn ngủi ngay thôi đó là led này sau đó
thì
Anh tên của loại Intex nó sẽ có khái
niệm là
class takes all aspects mà các bạn hình
như mình nhớ không lầm là unique Index
cũng cỏ như thế này nhưng mà unique
Index này bạn bản chất nó cũng là non
egestas neque được như bạn vừa đọc Ngoài
ra còn thêm một vài vài loại Inax nữa
không phải một vài cái tên Inax nữa
nhưng như mình ở Tổng hợp các bạn thực
chất là bản chất nó chỉ có hai cái loại
Inax là cras neque mà non-pressure nhé
Bởi vì nếu các bạn tra nữa u-nik nhìn
Jack này nó ra này đúng không các bạn sẽ
nghĩ à à Ông làm lừa tôi rõ ràng có thêm
loại này nữa nhưng mà không cái này nó
vẫn chỉn non-pressure thôi đấy chứ
ở đó là xong cái phần Iraq tiếp theo
nhảy sang bên view biển view này nó ngắn
hơn và nó cũng dễ hiểu hơn để để mình
thử chỉ có bạn nhá
là sử ở đây mình còn một bảng trước đi
mình có một bạn cũng là bảo nhân viên
này là sự là mình lưu lại thông tin nhân
viên bao gồm cả email và mật khẩu của
nhân viên ạ đương nhiên phải có lưu lại
email cực khổ mật khẩu của nhân viên để
mà nhân viên đăng nhập vào thì mình sẽ
kiểm tra là Email là Long nè chẳng hạn
mật khẩu là 123 thì thì mới được vào
đúng không cho
mấy đứa đăng nhập và sử là mình nhập mật
khẩu 2 3 4 thì mình sẽ kiểm tra trong
này thì sẽ báo lỗi Đúng không đấy
Ừ ok thì giả sử là mình lưu lại email
mật khẩu có lý do là như thế nhưng bây
giờ giả sử là một ông lập trình viên ông
đấy Kiểu
cách chạy lệnh select from nhânviên thì
này ông ấy chạy lệnh này để mà làm các
thư thứ ông ấy chạy tự nhiên ông ấy thấy
ra mật khẩu của bao nhiêu ông thế chết
đúng không
Thế chết ông ấy không được phép biết mật
khẩu của hai thậm chí đô thị cải mê luôn
bởi vì nó là thông tin những cảm yêu
kiểu là email khách hàng mà đúng không
ra là nhân viên hạn chế biết email khách
hàng để lúc mà nó nhảy việc cái nó ôm mà
đồng email đấy nhảy sang công ty khác để
mà mà cái tinh thì chết đúng không Thì
nên là ông ấy chỉ được phép Giả sử ông
ấy chỉ được phép lấy họ tên thôi chẳng ạ
thì làm như nào
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ bảo là Ừ thì ông ấy gõ
đầy đủ như thế này là được mà anh đúng
không mã họ họ tên như này không Nếu mà
như này thì ông đấy mà gõ đầy đủ tử tế
như này người tốt ông ấy có toàn quyền
động và cái bảng nhân viên này thì ông
ấy không tội gì mà lấy sẽ sao để lấy hết
thông tin cả đúng không Ông ấy Tại sao
mới phải gõ vừa phải mất công gõ dài hơn
kết hợp với việc là ông ấy sẽ không lấy
được những người thông tin nhạy cảm kia
đúng không Thì có bạn bảo là Ok Nếu thế
thì bây giờ em tách hẳn một bảng bảng
thông tin nhân viên vòng bảng là bảng
thông tin mật khẩu của nhân viên Ngạn
Thế thì làm như nào không Thực ra là
không ai làm thế Cả Thế bây giờ giả sự
là là mình phải có một bài toán ở đây đó
là không quay vòng cái gì cũng nghe rồi
Ông nhầm đấy nhá web là là để mà lọc
từng thằng một thôi chứ để lấy tên cột
lấy cô thì không phải que bây giờ
ạ Bây giờ thì bản thận bản chất của vấn
đề ở đây đó là gì đó là cùng cái bạn
nhân viên này nhưng mà tôi chỉ cho ông
lấy một vài cột của bà ngày thôi đúng
không Thì nó có khái niệm là view View
nó sẽ là dịch ra là góc nhìn đúng không
nó sẽ là mình chỉ được xem những vài
thông tin chi tiết là sử ở đây là sửa
đây mình có bảng sinh viên ở trọ sự thế
Ngon
Ừ mình nào không bảo nhân viên mình lấy
tạm bán sinh viên nhé sự đây mình lấy
được toàn bộ thông tin này Đúng chưa là
sử ở đây Cứ kệ không có dữ liệu gì cậy
nha đúng không ạ sử bây giờ ra sự là một
mã còn lại cảm đi mình không được phép
lấy một mã thì mình lấy như này chờ tiếc
đúng không Nhưng thằng nhân viên Đương
nhiên là sẵn như mình vừa nói nó không
tội gì mà đi đầy đủ ra như thế này mà nó
sẽ lấy xe Lexus Vì sao rồi mong đấy do
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo Grand view này rồi
mình đặt tên là gửi bưu đấy các bạn sẽ
để mua db2 này các bạn sẽ không động đây
nhờ cũng động sanrex in-shop các thửa
thường nhưng mà mình không giảm cái đấy
nữa mà mình sẽ chủ yếu là các bạn với
mấy cái câu lệnh liên quan kiến crash
này về chưa
tô màu luôn có điệp khúc đầu là crash
xong mà tên của cái đấy dụng led vừa rồi
Các bạn hãy press Index này thì bây giờ
này là qlistview này chưa redwood tên
của cái đấy tên của đấy ra xưởng mình là
tên là à
i-view họ tên sinh viên em ạ nghĩa không
có một mã đấy đúng không ạ sau đó các
bạn thêm chữ Apps nói là sau đó mình sẽ
thử nhé
ở đó thế này xong rồi và bây giờ thằng
một thằng cái thằng lập trình viên Liên
Kiệt nó nó không được động vào bản sinh
viên ở luôn mình khóa luôn không cho
động vào bạn sinh viên nữa nó chỉ được
động động vào vi vậy thôi và nó bây giờ
nó chỉ cần select sao form cày view này
Ừ thì bạn sẽ thấy đó nó sẽ chỉ ra cột họ
và tên thôi để trưa Nó sẽ không có cục
mã và bây giờ Bây giờ mình thử cho các
bạn xem thử nhé Bây giờ sửa mì Asus là
bạn sinh viên này bởi vì cột mã mình
không tự động tăng nên là mình phải điền
vào cột mãi nhá sẽ giao lưu mã là một
này Long này
này nghĩa này trở lại mình mình cứ ghi
ngay tại nhé Nói xuất để có một rồi đúng
không Bây giờ sự là select for xà phòng
này đó các bạn thấy là cái view nó vẫn
sẽ kế thừa nó sẽ đối chiếu đến thăm gốc
và thằng sinh viên để lấy thông tin về
chứ không phải mất công Insert vào trong
bảng không có khái niệm là bạn ở bảng hả
bản này mà nó bản chất nó làm review nó
sẽ là kiểu giống như các bạn chia sẻ ví
dụ ở đây anh mình đang có hai cái màn
hình để mà livestream này không các bạn
bạn sẽ các bạn chỉ được phép thấy một
màn hình một cái view của mình thôi mình
không cho các bạn xem cái vi của lại
đúng không Đấy cái view nó như thế cái
video này ngoài liên quan đến bảo mật
như thế nào có liên quan đến tốc độ xử
lý của nó sẽ nhanh hơn Tại sao giờ mình
sẽ ví dụ tiếp cho các bạn
à à ở tốc độ của nó nhanh về việc là
Ừ đúng rồi bây giờ như mình đã nói là
bây giờ mình sẽ khóa không cho cài nhân
viên CIA sẽ Lexus Phong Bản sinh viên
nữa hoặc hoặc bài toán thực ra đơn giản
thôi Nó là thằng nhân viên kia nó không
biết được bản gốc là bạn nào thế được
bởi vì
anh bởi vì yêu cầu u
anh bởi vì ở bây giờ mình đã ẩn ẩn cái
bảng tên là sinh viên rồi mà ngon thì nó
một là nó phải tra chuẩn nó phải gõ được
chính cái tên ba nhưng mà không Nó gần
như là các bạn thấy là thực là
sau khi mà giới hạn quyền như thế thì nó
sẽ giới hạn luôn Theo bạn luôn các bạn
không được động vào bạn luôn rồi Chưa ạ
em về cái khái niệm giới hạn quyền sâu
hơn nữa thì về sau càng càng môn db2 này
muốn db2 này là để hướng dẫn các bạn
Ừ thứ nhất là để cho luôn nằm ngang hơn
này các bạn sẽ thấy gần như toàn bộ
những cái ở đây nó đều tự giúp cho nhanh
hơn và thứ hai là nó liên quan đến bảo
mật hơn được chưa nó liên quan mà một
cành những buổi sau này mình dậy thì các
bạn sẽ đấy Ui nó hai dãy nó càng khóc
đúng kiểu càng sâu rồi bảo mật hơn nhân
viên không được phép tự ý Bây giờ giả sử
của ông nào Delete 1 phát cả hoặc lốp
một phát cả cái bàn đúng không thì chết
là đúng không Thì nó liên quan đến bảo
mật rất rõ việc là Delete Insert update
Delete Nói chung ngoài thậm chí là nhân
viên mà không cái thằng ông lập trình
viên đấy ông ấy còn không biết được tên
cột là gì luôn không biết là tên bảng là
gì luôn bởi vì nó bảo mật và phải đến
mức độ đấy nó không được phép biết tên
bảng tên cột nữa em đi chưa thì những
buổi sau này mình sẽ dạy càng dậy vì sau
các bạn sẽ thấy càng thấy hay thì chưa
em
Ừ đấy nhưng mà ok thì các bạn vừa rồi
Thầy qua về việc lưu này nhưng như mình
đã nói là nó sẽ giúp cho nhanh hơn Các
bạn thấy thực ra không nhanh hơn như cả
lại Ừ cái câu này đã mất công tạm vi rồi
sau đó nhỉ câu này với câu này thì ra là
tốc độ cái kiểu cái dòng lệnh ấy Các bạn
thấy rõ ràng câu này trong còn dài hơn
gấu này đúng không hả Chạy con này còn
hơn con này đúng không ạ
Ừ thì bây giờ bạn bản chất là ở cái bưu
này nhá Ừ nó
vì nó có thể liên quan đến nhiều bạn của
một lúc là sửa đây mình có bạn là bạn à
bạn lớp đi
thì mình cứ tạm giúp thai bồ sinh viên
ấy nhé
em thừa giúp thai bổ sinh viên này các
bạn Thể thờ ơ cái thằng view này kia nó
sẽ lách bởi thằng sinh viên này đúng
không như thằng view này nó độc lập nó
không được lốp đâu thì các bạn sẽ AK sao
như thế này nó chỉ đơn giản nó báo lỗi
rồi là không tìm thấy thằng sinh viên
này nghe các bạn phải phải luôn cả thằng
riêu này nhá proview này à
Ê bà chính với các bạn thấy là thằng
video này đang độc lập với thằng sinh
viên thành ra là bây giờ Đấy lý do mà
bây giờ mình tạm thêm bảng lớp sau đó
thì mình
Mình lưu lại nó kết kết hợp giữa cả bằng
lớp và các bạn sinh viên thì sẽ như thế
nào với mình tặng tạo bằng lớp này Ok
này mình Copy lại cái thằng này xuống
dưới nhé á
À
mà đây mình sẽ có mã lớp này
kiểu này
Ê con kia đúng không
bạn lớp
a free Print
ở
lớp phải cột mày là sự nha
cho các bạn sinh viên đó sau đó thì mình
sẽ in sốt lớp
a mã mình có bị tự động tăng đây là mình
cứ ngập cả mã này là xưởng lớp lập trình
này
đây sát thủ này
cô hồn đúng không và Insert
sinh viên em ạ
vi phạm Zalo
mã lợn mã sinh viên này tên này họ và
tên đúng không Nguyễn này trở lại và mã
lỡ là một này chẳng hạn ạ
Ừ được rồi đúng không mà bây giờ mình sẽ
rách sao for Giả sử của xe Lexus form2
bảng nữa nhé các bạn nhiều do không Mình
sẽ roi lớp on lớp chấm mã bằng Sinh viên
chấm mã lớp không ạ thật sự như thế này
a Bill không phải copy data đâu nhá Cái
này chỉ là cậu nó là thay thế cho câu c
nách rồi mà nó không hề copy data
Ừ đúng rồi chức năng là giới hạn snack
đấy cậu lấy ra chuẩn đấy nghĩa nó sẽ
chạy lại câu lệnh cernex thôi chứ nó
không phải là tạo thành một bảng mới để
mặt để mà copy data từ cái bạn từ cái
bạn tra không Không không phải như thế
đúng rồi nó tham chiếu về Chuẩn đấy thì
bây giờ mỗi lần mình muốn lấy toàn bộ
thông tin của sinh viên kèm với lớp 5
mình phải trả lại câu lệnh này thay vì
như thế Bây giờ mình thích thì mình cũng
có thể tạm của cái view tên là sinh viên
kèm lớp chẳng ạ Như này đó như thế này
chạy
à à Đây đang bảo lỗi Cái lỗi này Thực ra
cũng khá là hay may mà tự nhiên Hiền bị
lỗi này để mình trả lời các bạn luôn đó
là các bạn đọc kỹ lỗi đấy mình dịch ra
các bạn nhé là cột trong mỗi view hoặc
Phong trình phải là duy nhất unique là
duy nhất đúng không
một mã ở trong cái hại khi mà sẽ lách
này thì cột mã lại đang gặp lại thành ra
nó báo là lỗi thì chưa bảo Lặp lại nên
là lỗi thì bây giờ mình có thể ghi mình
phải ghi rõ ra là sự mình lấy á
thông tin sinh viên này nhờ mình không
lấy
Ừ mình không lấy cột à ra xử mình thông
tin sinh viên mình vẫn đầy đủ đi Nhưng
mà thông tin Lớp mình chỉ lấy cột tên
của lớp thôi mình không lấy cột mã của
lớp nữa
cho các bạn xem thử nhé thì đây thấy rõ
ra là không có cột nào là cột kiểu nó bị
lặp lại bị trùng đúng không thì các bạn
class đường này
à à cô tên cũng bị trùng
như thế lại phải sửa lại tiếp đúng không
Chắc mình phải ghi rõ ra rồi mình sẽ ghi
rõ ở đây là mã sinh viên đi rõ hết ra đi
sinh viên chấm Họ này
sinh viên chẳng tên
à À không không không không thì ra không
cần như thế
Mình ở đây ác tên lớp và được mà
khi bé đây thế này là xong mà
A phẩy phẩy nữa phải lấy nữa
ở đó được rồi đúng không ạ Và bây giờ
mình chỉ cần select sao for cái view này
à
Ừ thế bạn thấy là cái câu lệnh select
này chắc chắn nó sẽ ngắn hơn cái câu
lệnh này đúng không
khi bé gần nhất thứ hai cái bài toán ở
đây từ B2 các bạn học bạn sẽ thấy là
những cái clip này tạo ra ấy nó sẽ được
lưu lưu lại đúng không sẽ giảm nó sẽ
được lưu lại và mỗi khi là mình truy vấn
đến cái được lưu lại này tốc độ nó nhanh
hơn đến việc các bạn phải ghi lại một
câu lệnh đầy đủ như thế này và khi người
bạn Các bạn truyền cái con lệnh này lên
một con server thì đương nhiên có lệnh
càng ngắn càng ngắn như thế này này đúng
không tốc độ nó sẽ càng nhanh hơn Nói
chung là cái này vẫn liên quan đến bài
Toản à tốc độ là nhanh hơn đây
a mã chạy nhanh hơn vì đã biên dịch là
câu lệnh nhé
em không cần phải viết lại câu truy vấn
nhé ờ ờ chuyện câu lệnh lên sơ cho nhanh
hơn với bị nó ngắn hơn nữa nhé và bảo
mật hơn về chưa để tác dụng của Bưu đó
còn cách xóa như nào thì các bạn cũng
vừa thấy mình sẽ chọn group như này đúng
nó bị xóa
ở đó thì các bạn vừa rồi nghe được qua
Iraq và view chữa như mình đã nói cú
phát của nó rất là ngắn thread in black
mask review xong là tên của cái đấy
không xong rồi Thế là xong đúng không Nó
chẳng có gì kiểu khó cả tôi đấy mình
được dạy Cái này đúng kiểu cải cả buổi
học indec và view mình chưa mất nổi 5
phút để học xong cái cú pháp của nó
trong ngồi thầy ra bài tập là em tạo
nhiều video tạo nhiều hình a tạo Đúng
rồi Tại nhiều view tạo nhiều Index vào
cho quen hết mình thương sửa mình không
hiểu ý nghĩa của cái đầu lắm nhớ khi
mình mình đọc kỹ lại về mình cái được
pv2 này mình thấy thực sự rất là hay
đúng không
cái Story bootcd về sau mình sẽ dạy các
bạn nhé và Story Mode của nó khái niệm
khác hoàn toán
khi trích đoạn
Ok Bây giờ là lại đến cái giây phút mà
nhiều người đợi nhất
chứ không phải xem bóng đá rồi nhé mà sẽ
là
Cho xem về hết khủng đúng không Mình đã
từng nọ à mình đã từng
chủ đề cập ở đây đó là
Ừ nếu hacker hack được dp của bạn thì
Ừ thì bạn làm thế nào để phòng chống
trước khi giao sự Cứ chắc chắn các bạn
sẽ bị hack đã làm cách nào để nó không
vì nó không hiểu
đọc được thông tin nhạy cảm các thứ thứ
đúng không
cho mình nhớ là mình có lưu cũng
ờ ờ
khi nhìn thấy hình bài bị xóa được mở
bài bị xoáy ở đây
30 bài toán ở đây nhé ờ
số bài toán ở đây anh ngày đề cập gia sử
vì 1 ngày đẹp trời các bạn
thay thay được con máy tính mới
thì các bạn vứt có máy tính đi vào sọt
rác sau đó thì tự nhiên một ông ở đó ông
nhặt được con ổ cứng của con máy tính cũ
các bạn vào trong đấy có database của
một triệu khách hàng khi cài đặt ra bay
đầy đương nhiên như mình đã nói là các
bạn kiểu gì cũng phải lưu thông tin
email và mật khẩu khách à để mà khách
hàng để đăng nhập được đúng không Thế
nên không có chuyện mà rút ổ cắm cả rút
server Nhưng mấy ông kia em nói thì bài
toán ở đây là khi mà khách cơ khách được
vào đã ta bây nó xem được gió mây thì nó
cũng không đăng nhập được vào tài khoản
khách à
cô giáo sư nó không có quyền để mà sửa
thông tin các thứ nhưng mà nó vẫn đọc
được đấy thì nó không đăng nhập được vào
tài khoản Thế nhà thì đấy gọi là tao
bệnh ổn hiểu chứ mấy ông cứ bảo rút dây
nguồn cái thứ thứ thì thì lúc đấy Quá
Muộn rồi Nó đã copy xử với dữ liệu đấy
xong mày nó mất rồi đúng không
Ừ nó copy sửa dữ liệu đấy Sao mày nói
thì mày ông rút nó trả nghĩa gì cả đúng
không Bây giờ quan trọng là khi nó có
rồi thì làm thế nào để nó không đăng
nhập được Vào nó không dịch ngược được
bởi vì ngoài việc nó không đăng nhập
được vào nhé Có rất nhiều ông ở đây tôi
nói thẳng rất nhiều ông ở đây đang dùng
một mật khẩu của một tài khoản à Dùng
một mật khẩu cho nhiều tài khoản mạng xã
hội luôn Ví dụ loa kéo anh hiểu là i
love you Hay mật khẩu tên là password
mật khẩu để password Anh chưa thế cho
rất nhiều tài khoản mạng xã hội nghĩa
thằng kia mà biết được email của ông
thằng kia mà biết được mật khẩu rồi nó
thử đăng nhập cái tài khoản đấy vào
Facebook của ông mà vào được thì ra đúng
không
Ừ thì tính ra trước đấy gì à
Thì hack khách hàng đi kiện thành lập
thì việc
anh không đúng không Bây giờ mình phải
giải quyết bài toán đấy để tránh bị kiện
đúng
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ đấy thì cái bài toán ở đây là các bạn
có nhiều bạn đã biết qua về cái khái
niệm là lưu mật khẩu không nên lưu dạng
grentech tất cả lưu lại mật khẩu là vô
nghĩa là mình mình lưu đúng được 123 là
123 luôn đấy là kiểu thôi như thế Do thô
thì ra thằng Facebook thôi gần đây nó bị
dính vào cái vụ labjack này là nó đúng
là lưu lại mật khẩu thô thế của người
dùng bao nhiêu triệu tài khoản tại mình
chả thử các bạn xem
mình có đọc qua bài đấy đây
Ừ nó lưu lại đúng mật khẩu của khách
hàng là dạng thô trong nhiều năm liền
đấy
300 triệu trăm triệu tài khoản Nếu chưa
xử mà hacker mà Hack đầu vào bê hoa cao
ra xử giả sử như là lập trình viên của
Facebook select sao được for bảng user
mà không dùng view đáy đề cập heo để cập
cái nước đi với học đúng không Thì tự
nhiên lại thấy cái cột email password
đấy và và nó kiểu không hay mã hóa gì cả
đúng không ai vào đọc cũng đọc được thế
thì vui lắm
anh ở đây ở dưới này bọn nó khẳng định
này thằng thằng Facebook nó bảo lại đã
là lập trình viên Chúng tôi có thể truy
cập được nhưng mà chúng tôi không làm gì
cả Chẳng chẳng ai tin được cái lời ông
đấy đúng không nghe có lại toàn rồi ông
thế nên phải toán ở đây là là
ừ ừ
thì các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ phải dùng cái một cái gọi là hát
là mã hóa mã hóa mật khẩu ở đây nó có
khuyên là không nên dùng những cái hà mã
hóa này Tại sao lại thế
a cho dù hà mã hóa này hiện tại có thể
dịch ngược được ra không không dịch
ngược ra nhưng tại sao Thế thì bài này
sẽ đề cập thì chưa Bên mình sẽ cho các
bạn một ví dụ rất đơn giản nhé ra sự
khẩu mình em 123 đây như mình mã hóa nó
lại nếu mà giờ xử có nhiều ông khái niệm
là bây cốt 64 em ạ thường mà chẳng đây
cũng là một kiểu mã hóa bình thường em
mã hòa như này để chiếc bạn bè ở chính
tại sao Bùi việc mã hóa này có thể dịch
ngược được ra sự là
nó là bay cốt 64 đúng không
Tôi thường ai chưa Bạn bè tôi là như thế
này cách cách cách trêu của lập trình
viên nó sẽ thiếu rồi nha đã sự tôi sẽ gõ
lại trẻ trâu đấy Chẳng ạ
Tôi thường này kiểu gì như thế này nếu
mà ông nào lên tường là tôi thương chị
Thoa tôi sẽ bình luận như này và nếu
chẳng hiểu gì cả
mà nó lại êm cốt nha là mã hỏa nhé
xe tải mã khóa này Đấy nó sẽ ra đoạn này
thôi Tôi thường ấy copy đoạn này đi trêu
trêu
sử dụng mày thật như này xong rồi đoạn
Mã hóa sau đấy thì có nhiều ông nếu mà
ông không biết cha thì ông sẽ cháy nhiều
cái đoạn này là gì Chẳng biết nó chửi
mình nghe Nó khen mình cái cơ Thế Nhân
nếu mà ông ấy tra được ví dụ đi cốc đúng
không Ngoài tra dịch ngược Lai đứng yên
này kiểu sẽ ra nha ấy bạn mày theo dõi
trẻ trâu không
Ừ tôi sẽ Châu tôi biết mẹ em không có lẽ
Em chuẩn bị chat tôi chạy sâu đâu
Ừ
đấy thì thì chúng ta không nên dùng
những cái loại mã hóa mà có thể dịch
được được như thế để lưu lại mật khẩu
người dùng đúng không Bởi vì bởi vì
thằng ai cờ nó thể dịch được đúng không
Thì ở đây nó có đề cập bạn này có đề cập
liên quan đến cả 10 năm 10 năm thì nó
hiện tại nó không để dịch ngược được
mấy cái mã hóa này nó rất khó để dịch
Nhược nhìn như không thể đây thì các bạn
sẽ tra là em cốt 10 năm em ạ
anh hỏi ra gì cả online này đây khi ra
xử mình sẽ mã hóa thử 123 nhé các bạn
thấy nó sẽ ra hẳn một cái đoạn Mã hóa
md5 hoặc là sát như thế này đúng không
chưa nó sẽ ra một cái đoạn như thế này
và các bạn không dịch ngược được cái này
ra các bạn có thể tra Google là kiểu đi
cốt là định dịch ngược ra nó có thể ra
được cái trang này những trang này điêu
đấy nó không dịch được đâu nó chỉ nó chỉ
so sánh vừa những cái thằng mà đã nó đã
dịch sang từ 123 sang số này ạ Từ số này
nó nó sẽ gọi là search như này để xem có
ra được cái thằng góp 20 đấy thì thôi
chứ nó không dịch ngược được ra thì chưa
ừ ừ
Ừ Thì bài toán ở đây nó cũng là như thế
nếu mà ông mà
Ừ
nếu mà ông mà mã hóa mật khẩu 123 nó sẽ
ra một cái con số như thế này đúng rồi
nó khái niệm từ điển lại nó khái niệm ở
đây nó để tôi đọc vì cái ông nhé Nó
Rainbow table tức là
tin tức là nó khái niệm là
Đó là kiểu nó sẽ tạo ra âm cái bảng và
bảng ấy sẽ lưu lại mật khẩu mật khẩu thô
mật khẩu đã mã hóa khi nó chìm việc So
sánh mật khẩu đã mã hóa đấy thì nó thể
ra được mật khẩu thô của ông đúng trước
Ừ đấy Nó kêu từ điển và kiểu vét cạn mấy
ông kia nói xa chuẩn và khái niệm nó nên
bông thấy bồ được chưa
Tại sao không dịch ngược được bởi vì à
Cái máy ghế hà mã hóa này mình không nhớ
Chính xác vì cách nó mã hóa như nào đâu
nhưng nó cắt chuỗi rồi các thử nó lằng
lằng nhằng lắm nhưng mà như mình đang đề
cập ở đây là nó giả sử nó có cái lưu lại
hẳn Rainbow thấy bồ đến hàng tỉ bản ghi
đúng không Nó đã mã hóa rất nhiều về cụm
từ rồi Thế nên là hoàn toàn là khi mà nó
so sánh Giả sử các bạn đang dùng cái mặt
cái mật khẩu lưu lại là như thế này
không Nó hoàn toàn biết được
cái mạnh cái mật khẩu gốc của các bạn là
123 mất rồi bởi vì nó tra theo đơn mâu
thấy bồ để ra đúng không
Vì thế nên là các bạn sẽ không dùng mày
cái mật khẩu mà đến năm này hai cái
sharp1 này được nữa Bởi vì ạ
a123 md5 cho dù cho dù các bạn bây giờ
mã hóa hay là ngày mai hay ngày kia mã
hóa nó vẫn chỉ ra cái cụ mày thôi
thì tại sao tự nhiên mình phải đề cập
với thời gian ở đây bởi vì tức à
ở cây chuối này không ở thay đổi thì cái
đoạn Mã hóa không bao giờ thay đổi thế
nên là thằng hacker mà một khi nó đã có
cái bảng giờ xử thằng hacker nào bây giờ
còn ngựa chẳng có cái bên bố người bồ để
nó thì dịch ngược được ra mật khẩu của
các bạn mà lượng người dùng dùng mật
khẩu phổ biến rất là đông đúc Như à
Thống kê là người loại mật khẩu phổ biến
nhất thế giới giống như tôi vừa nói có
cả mật khẩu tên là a i love you Này Hack
password này
hai ông kia vừa nói là anh yêu em mà Thì
phải đấy như có đấy Việt Nam mình nằm
trong cũng nằm trong danh sách mật khẩu
kiểu để ra đơn giản đấy thành ra là ông
nào mà bể mật khẩu là ai love you
chẳnghạn đây không ai là kiểu này ạ khi
xảy ra cái cụm này gì đúng không
Ừ thì hoàn toàn là giả sử hacker có cụm
này và nó sẽ là ai love you rồi đúng
không có phải nó lại nó sẽ đăng nhập
được tất cả những cái ông tất cả những
người ông nào còn mật khẩu là i love you
đúng không
anh không không không phải đoán đun cách
mã hóa nếu mà các bạn làm random cái mã
hóa thì lại phức tạp theo cửa các bạn
không đăng nhập được đúng không
ở đây đây Thế nên là bây giờ cách giải
quyết bài toán nó là như thế này được
chưa cái giải quyết bài toán nó là như
thế này
anh ở đây Bạn để anh đấy đi Cập là phải
thêm Sam San dịch Cả thêm muối tất cả
Sao ở đây nó như thế này
ạ Bây giờ giả sử là mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ thêm một tí muối là ABC như
này xong rồi Ghét với mật khẩu có bạn
123 kết hợp với a b c
Ừ để mã hóa nó ra cũng ở dùng hàm ở đến
năm nhé Đấy nó sẽ mã hóa nó sẽ ra như
thế này 123 ABC này
Ừ tao nó sẽ ra ngay đúng không các bạn
lưu nó lại và ô ngoài cũng là một hai ba
giờ xử lý thế nhưng mà
cách muối của mỗi ông khác nhau đúng
không Thì có ông mặn có nhạc đúng không
ngủ mỗi khác nhau lại cái rét em ạ thì
nó sẽ lại ra như này
anh đúng không
đó thế là xong Ừ thì rõ ràng mà tui
hacker em có thứ nhất là Hacker sẽ khó
đoán hơn cái mật khẩu gốc của các bạn vì
là nó sẽ phải kết hợp thêm cả xa nữa
đúng không để mà ra được mật khẩu đấy
Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là
khi bé lý do mà được nhiều ông cũng
nhiều nhiều nơi nó vẫn khuyến cáo công
lên để mật khẩu Nó khá dài và kết hợp
trình tự đặc biệt để cho thằng ấy cơ nó
không dùng Rainbow table để đoán được
chứ mày cái chữ mấy kịch mật khẩu của
mấy ông chỉ toàn số hãy chỉ toàn là chữ
thì chắc chắn là có nằm trong cái danh
sách Rainbow table của nó rồi mà nó tra
ra rất là nhanh
Ừ ok thì thực ra là đến đến cái ngưỡng
mà thêm cái San như thế này là thằng
hacker nó rất vất vả để dịch ra đường
mật khẩu các bạn rồi được chưa Ừ nhưng ở
đây bạn này vẫn bảo lắm Nếu giả sử là
thái cơ nó có một con siêu máy tính nó
vẫn có thể ghét hay hài về nhau để mà
dịch ngược được để mà tạo ra đầm ren ren
bông hay bù đấy trăm tỷ chịu thì bạn ghi
để mà nó vẫn ra được những cái mã hóa
này để mà lấy lấy được tài khoản đúng
không Thì cái này một điểm hay này chính
vì xa này đang khắc khác nhau nên là cho
dù nó dị ngược được của ông này thì
không có nghĩa là ông này cùng mật khẩu
nhé cùng Mật khẩu nhà đúng không Thì
cũng không Nghĩa là ông nó vào vào được
của ông này đúng không em trước đấy Cái
điểm hay của xa này Nghĩa giả sử nó cố
để hack được một người thì cái người
cùng chung mật khẩu cũng không chưa chắc
đã bị hack bởi vì hai ông xa khác nhau ở
đây nhưng mà bài toán như mình vừa nói
giờ xử nó có con siêu máy tính nó thể dò
ra được đúng không Nó vẫn do đã được thì
thêm một cái nữa là thêm paper được chưa
rất nhiều công ty đặc biệt liên quan đến
bảo mật bây giờ thì ngay có thêm cái này
thì cách paper paper là dung dịch là mùi
tiêu
3 cách bơ bản chất à
cho mình mình sẽ mã hóa cả San cả
password và kết hợp với paper thôi Nhưng
mà cái popup này thì sao cái tơ này thì
một là ông lưu thẳng vào trong cốt
à hài hài giả sử là tôi thường ngồi
trước tôi làm ở công ty cũ tổn thưởng
ngày lưu lại ví dụ là tôi hội đấy làm ở
trường mà không lưu sự là thêm cái chữ à
bách khoa này chẳng hạn BK này một cái
thiện trước năm à Xong rồi tôi mã hóa cả
ba thằng ngày vào cái thi.can càng càng
có nhiều chuỗi ghép vào với nhau thì có
phải tăng độ phức tạp lên không đúng
không để cái thứ nhất thế hay là như tôi
vừa nói là cái này lại không
anh lại không lưu ở trong đầy bể không
đi ở trong B các bạn lưu ý thẳng vào
trọng cốt hoặc là lưu lại và trong có
ông kia đang bảo lưu trong file
khi cài đặt
hoặc cả lưu lưu lại ở đâu đấy nói chung
và cơ thể xong ngồi ghét cái đoạn đấy
vào với nhau thì tăng độ khó lên rất
nhiều
ở đó thế thôi
máy đánh bài tổng hợp này được ra tổng
tập hợp nó là như thế nghĩa là các bạn
thấy là thì các bạn vừa rồi được hiểu
thêm về cái vụ là
bí mật khẩu các bạn nó đang mông lung
Nhưng mà trò đùa như thế nào đúng không
và lập trình viên những cái nhà bảo mật
sẽ có những cách nào để mã giải quyết
bài toán đấy đúng không Các bạn thấy khá
hay mà đúng không Nghĩa là khi mà
sau Khi mặt thằng kia là sự có được
database thì nó không thể đăng nhập được
vào tài khoản các bạn - trong Facebook
Facebook nó cứ để lỗ thông tìm người
dùng suốt trai vãi thì
Ừ thì có thêm những cái Tí muối này thêm
tí hạt tiêu đúng không Thì sẽ giúp cho
bảo mật nó ổn hơn chưa hi vọng sau này
tôi không
Ai biết đâu mấy ông lại về sau làm ra
những cái trang web gì đó rồi tôi vào
đăng nhập vào tự nhiên vì sao tôi bị mất
nick Chỉ vì mày ông cốt đểu phong lưu
mấy cái thông tin kiểu như này đúng
không ạ
ở đó thưa đó đó đã tổng hợp kiến thức
của cả đội hôm nay kết hợp với thêm một
tí kiến thức nữa rồi không
ừ ừ
từ lúc nhập mật khẩu như thế nào đúng
không nhầm mật khẩu thì thì nó đơn giản
thôi nó là nó là
bạn Nhập mật khẩu làm 123 thì
Ừ thì nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ đương nhiên nó sẽ
phải kết hợp buổi san của từng ông nó
cộng ngồi san của từng ông 1 sau đó thì
nó mã hóa để mà nó khớp với cái à ở khớp
của cái mật khẩu đương nhiên nó sẽ lâu
hơn một tí bởi vì nó cộng thêm xanh thậm
chí paper Giống như mình vừa nói nhưng
mà thực ra cái này là phải toán liên
quan đến việc là kiểm tra mật khẩu
Từ nay về sau vì sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn
về hẳn
anh xuống làm một cái trang web các thử
mà Thì mình sẽ đề cập cụ thể hơn
ở Zalo bảo mật khuẩn không bị sẽ không
đề cập về máy công ty lớn ở đây rồi sợ
lắm à Công ty Việt Nam thì nữa đấy
ừ ừ
Ờ Ờ bạn kia đang nói về cách mà các ông
lớn mã hóa như thế nào á cả ông lầm mã
hóa thật cao có rất nhiều cách có thể là
pepper + San + password nhưng có nhiều
ông thì ngược lại là san của password
Rồi mày cũng Tapper và compair rồi ông
ấy công khai được thì các không quan
trọng bởi vì sàn rồi password mã hóa nó
đủ rất phức tạp rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi thực sự thì về cái bảo mật
thì nó vẫn chỉ ở mức tương đối mà đúng
không Nếu mà thắng hai cô có siêu máy
tính nó ngồi tra thì nó vẫn xảy ra được
thôi Nhưng mà kể cái việc khiến cho nó
phải rất rất khó xa hơn thì chỉ mới mới
đạt được yêu cầu không
Ừ thôi chào mọi người mọi người cha đi
đá banh sẽ nhập Xem đá banh vui vẻ không
chọn người nhé